PROBABLY TOMORROW SOMETIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Reporter: THANK YOU.
>> Dana: THAT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WRAPPING UP
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEDIA.
HE RESPONDED TO THE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST JOE BIDEN, HIS
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE INTO THE
NEW REVELATIONS IN THE CASE
AGAINST MICHAEL FLYNN.
HE TALKED BROADLY ABOUT ALL
SORTS OF THINGS, TALKING ABOUT
NORTH KOREA, I THOUGHT HE MADE A
LITTLE BIT OF NEWS ON CHINA.
AND I ALSO THOUGHT IF I CAN HAVE
A PERSONAL PRIVILEGE POINT FROM
A COMMUNICATION STANDPOINT, I
THOUGHT THIS PRESS CONFERENCE
WAS LEAPS, YARDS SO MUCH BETTER
THAN THE ONE FROM THE PAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
THE QUESTIONS WERE VERY GOOD,
THEY WERE ON POINT, AND THE
PRESIDENT SHOWED A LOT OF
EMPATHY AND SUCH KNOWLEDGE
ACROSS A BROAD RANGE OF TOPICS.
SO THAT IS MY VOTE, BUT I WILL
TAKE IT AROUND THE TABLE TO GET
THOUGHTS FROM THE GROUP HERE.
THIS IS YOUR "THE FIVE," WE ARE
ALL HERE AND LISTENING INTENTLY.
JESSE, LET ME START WITH YOU,
ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT HE
BROUGHT UP?
HE TALKED ABOUT EVERYTHING HE
COULD.
>> Jesse: HE ZEROED IN ON
CHINA PRETTY SPECIFICALLY.
WHY WERE PEOPLE IN WUHAN?
ALLOWED TO LEAVE TO THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
CHINA HAS TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION, AND THEY HAVE NOT
ANSWERED IT AT ALL.
HE ALSO SAYS THAT HE HAS A VERY
HIGH DEGREE OF CONFIDENCE THAT
THE VIRUS CAME FROM THIS LAB IN
WUHAN, THAT WAS PRETTY
INTERESTING.
AND HE KIND OF WAS BRAINSTORMING
ABOUT WAYS TO FINANCIALLY
SANCTION CHINA, WHETHER IT WAS
TARIFFS, DEBT PAYMENTS, SO HE
DOES SEEM TO HAVE SERIOUSLY
CHANGED HIS TONE FROM TWO MONTHS
AGO WHEN HE WAS COMPLEMENTARY
ABOUT HOW THE CHINESE HAVE
HANDLED IT ONLY HEALS OF THE
TRADE DEAL, TO NOW AFTER
LEARNING FROM THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE HOW THE THING ESCAPED
AND THE WORLD WAS NOT WARNED
ABOUT IT, IT LOOKS LIKE IT AS A
WHOLE NEW BALL GAME WITH THE
CHINESE.
HE ALSO WANDERED IN WITH SWEDEN
AND BRAZIL, THEY TRIED TO DO
HERD.
AND THAT DOES NOT WORK VERY
WELL.
AND HE GAVE HIMSELF A PAT ON THE
BACK FOR LOCKING ON THE COUNTRY,
AND PREDICTING IT WOULD BE AN
UGLY SECOND QUARTER AND BOUNCED
BACK STRONGLY IN THE THIRD OR
POTENTIALLY THE FOURTH.
>> Dana: GREG, ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I THOUGHT WAS VERY
GOOD.
AND YOU MIGHT EXPECT THAT MORE
AND A LONG FORM INTERVIEW THAN A
PRESS CONFERENCE LIKE THIS, IT
WAS THE QUESTION, YOU SAID THAT
WE ARE IN A WAR AGAINST A VIRUS,
SO WHAT DOES VICTORY LOOK LIKE
TO YOU, AND I THOUGHT HIS ANSWER
WAS MEASURED AND EMPATHETIC AND
LONG REACHING.
>> Greg: IT WAS PRETTY GOOD.
AND I THINK THAT THE MEDIA, WE
ARE ALMOST FOUR YEARS INTO THIS
RESIDENCY, STILL FAILING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT TRUMP IS.
THE LITERALNESS THAT THEY TAKE
HIS OPTIMISM.
HE HAS A MACHINE BUILT ON
OPTIMISM.
AND I WILL STEAL THIS JOKE FROM
SOMEONE ON TWITTER WHO SAID HE
WAS OFFICIALLY ASKED MORE ABOUT
TARA READE THEN JOE BIDEN HAS
BEEN ASKED, WHICH WAS FUNNY.
BUT I WANT TO BRING UP TO THE
POINT ABOUT AND TALKING ABOUT
THE ONE-SIDED TRAVEL, I SEEM TO
REMEMBER A DASHING GOOD LOOKING
TV ANCHOR ON "THE FIVE" BACK ON
JANUARY 27TH SCREAMING AT THE
TOP OF HIS LUNGS SAYING, WHY ARE
PEOPLE FROM CHINA LEAVING AND
COMING HERE, BUT WE ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO GO TO CHINA?
I REMEMBER YELLING THAT, IT WAS
LIKE JANUARY 20TH, AS IF IT WAS
YESTERDAY.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO PUT A LITTLE
FEATHER IN MY CAP.
>> Dana: I REMEMBER IT TOO.
>> Greg: I PLAY IT HOME WHEN I
AM ALONE, WHICH IS OFTEN.
>> Dana: I WOULD SAY, KATIE,
HIS ANSWER ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND
TARA READE WAS VERY GOOD, AND AS
I AM TOLD, WE HAVE THE SLOT,
LET’S PLAY THAT IN CASE ANYBODY
MISSED IT.
THIS IS HOW IT WENT.
>> President Trump: I DON’T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
I DON’T KNOW EXACTLY, I THINK
YOU SHOULD RESPOND, YOU KNOW?
IT COULD BE FALSE ACCUSATIONS.
I KNOW ALL ABOUT FALSE
ACCUSATIONS.
I HAVE BEEN FALSELY CHARGED
NUMEROUS TIMES.
AND THERE IS SUCH A THING.
IF YOU LOOK AT BRETT KAVANAUGH,
THIS IS AN OUTSTANDING MAN.
HE WAS FALSELY CHARGED.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH HIM WAS AN
ABSOLUTE DISGRACE TO OUR COUNTRY
COUNTRY.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, KATIE,
YOUR THOUGHTS, I THOUGHT IT WAS
DEFINITELY ANSWERED, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> Katie: I WOULD AGREE THAT
IT WAS ANSWERED.
HE DID NOT ATTACK JOE BIDEN, HE
PUT THE FOCUS BACK ON DUE
PROCESS.
AND ANSWERING TO THE CHARGES OF
YOUR ACCUSER PUBLICLY ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU ARE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IN THE UNITED STATES,
BUT HE ALSO PUTS IT ON THE LEFT
AND EVERYBODY WHO’S CHAMPION THE
IDEA THAT YOU SHOULD BELIEVE
EVERY SINGLE ACCUSATION WITHOUT
ANY DUE PROCESS OR VETTING.
SO, HE PUTS THE STANDARD BACK ON
THE LEFT BY MAKING THEM PLAY BY
THEIR OWN RULES WHEN IT COMES TO
HOW THEY WANT TO HANDLE THESE
SITUATIONS.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE DECIDED THAT
THEY WANT TO THE STANDARD OF YOU
BELIEVE ANY ACCUSATION THAT ANY
WOMAN MAKES AGAINST ANY MAN,
BECAUSE MEN ARE EVIL AND THEY
ARE ALL ENGAGED IN SOME
SEXUAL ABUSE TOWARDS WOMEN
BECAUSE OF THE PATRIARCHY, BUT
THEN YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN, THE
LEADING CANDIDATE WHO IS NOW THE
NOMINEE OF THE PARTY WHO HAS AN
ACCUSATION THAT COMES OUT WITH
COOPERATION FROM MULTIPLE
PEOPLE, BY THE WAY, AND THEY
HAVE A CHOICE TO MAKE ABOUT
WHETHER THEY ARE GOING TO
VIOLATE THEIR OWN STANDARDS ON
THIS ISSUE THEY HAVE HAD FOR TWO
YEARS OR WHETHER THEY MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE NOMINEE?
>> Dana: AND LET ME ASK YOU
ABOUT THE NEWS THAT WE FOUND OUT
RIGHT BEFORE THEY SHOW THAT
TOMORROW MORNING JOE BIDEN IS
GOING TO TAKE QUESTIONS FROM
MORNING JOE ABOUT TARA READE.
EXCUSE ME.
>> Juan: WE HAVE ALL ADVISED
THAT IT WILL BE GOOD FOR THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT TO GET OUT
THERE AND ADDRESS THIS.
AND EVEN TO GO INTO THE RECORD
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE
AND SAY, THIS IS WHAT EXISTS AND
THIS IS WHAT DOES NOT.
BUT JUST TO BE TRANSPARENT,
DANA, JUST TO CLEAR THE AIR IS
GOOD FOR EVERYBODY.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS QUITE
CAREFUL IN TERMS OF HIS OWN
RESPONSE BY SAYING, HE HAS
DENIED THINGS, AND IF PEOPLE ON
THE RIGHT, IN SOME CASES ARE
TRYING TO EXPLOIT IT FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES WOULD ACCEPT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S ALLOCATION,
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO WHEN VICE PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN APPEARS ON MSNBC AND
SAYS, YES, I DENY THE CHARGES.
THAT HAS BEEN SET IN THE WAY
THAT THEY ACCEPT HIS DENIAL IN
THE FACE OF TAPES AND SIGN
CHECKS AND ALL THE REST.
LET ME FINISH HERE.
>> Jesse: THERE IS ONE CHECK
WITH A CONSENSUAL SITUATION AND
NO PAYOFFS WERE A SEXUAL ASSAULT
ALLEGATION.
THAT’S DIFFERENT.
>> Juan: THERE IS A PAYOFF TO
A PORN STAR THAT HE DENIES.
I JUST THINK ONCE HE WAS MADE IN
TERMS OF THE TOP OF THAT WHERE
THE PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT
POTENTIALLY EVEN BRINGING
MICHAEL FLYNN BACK INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE BASIS OF
SOME FBI MEMOS THAT CAME FROM
MICHAEL FLYNN’S LAWYERS, AND I
THINK IT WAS AN AGGRESSIVE LEAP
BY THE DEFENSE LAWYER THAT PLAYS
TO THE PRESIDENT’S GRIEVANCE
AGAINST THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, BUT SPECIFICALLY THE
FBI.
AND IT IS SETTING UP THE
CONDITIONS FOR A PRESIDENTIAL --
>> Dana: CAN YOU HOLD?
GREG, DID YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON
BIDEN?
>> Greg: WE ARE MISSING A BIG
POINT.
HE HAS A HUGE DISADVANTAGE WITH
TRUMP.
YOU KNEW WHAT YOU WERE GETTING
INTO WITH TRUMP.
SLEEPING WAS STORMY DANIELS, I
CAN SEE THAT HAPPENING.
I DON’T WANT TO SEE IT, BUT I
KNOW THAT IT CAN HAPPEN.
BUT WITH BIDEN, YOU FIND OUT
THAT HE IS DIRTY, RIGHT?
HE HAS TO DEFEND IT WHETHER IT
IS ABOUT BANKS, BECAUSE HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE MORAL
ALTERNATIVE TO DONALD TRUMP.
NOT JUST FOR THE DEMOCRATS, BUT
FOR THE NEVER-TRUMPERS.
IT IS THE SOLUTION FOR BILL
KRISTOL.
HE WAS NO MORAL CHOICE OVER EVIL
TRUMP EVEN THOUGH RUMORS SWIRLED
AROUND TO JOE BIDEN FOR YEARS
ABOUT HIS BEHAVIOR, ABOUT HIS
SWIMMING HABITS.
WE KNEW THAT -- SO THE THING,
THIS IS GOING TO BE A LOT HARDER
FOR HIM TO DEAL WITH THEM PEOPLE
THINK.
YOU JUST CAN’T SAY, BUT LOOK AT